[Musik]
Druck auf dem Heizkessel Ampel streitet
Land verzweifelt 22 Uhr an diesem
Donnerstag sie sind bei uns und das ist
gut so längere Übergangsfristen mehr
Wahl fernwärmeplanung Härtefallregelung
am Ende könnte aus dem sogenannten
heizhammer vielleicht doch noch ein
praktikables Gesetz werden nur warum es
jetzt und warum streiten sich die
Regierungsparteien wie die
heizkesselflicker und das auf offener
Bühne warum verunsichert man die Bürger
so dass mittlerweile niemand mehr weiß
was er tun oder besser lassen soll wir
müssen reden mit diesen Gästen
der Generalsekretär der SPD Kevin
Kühnert
der Generalsekretär der CDU Mario Chaya
katrin Göring-Eckardt von den Grünen
der BDI-Präsident Siegfried Rossmann
von der Zeit
und der dänische Journalist Matthias
Sonne
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt alle Gäste der Sendung
nochmal ausgesprochen herzlich der
Streit um das Heizen zwischen Grünen und
FDP erinnerte an einen Glaubenskrieg
irgendwie und die sind bekanntlich
schlecht zu gewinnen
es kann aber nicht sein dass in einer
fortschrittskoalition nur einen
Koalitionspartner für den Fortschritt
verantwortlich ist und die anderen für
die Verhinderung von Fortschritt hier
sind einfach unfassbar viele Fehler
deswegen sind hier hier brauchen wir ein
neues Gesetz
besondere Aufmerksamkeit in den
parlamentarischen Beratungen bedürfen
die vorgetragenen Bedenken im Hinblick
auf Finanzierbarkeit und Umsetzbarkeit
das ist nicht aufgesetzt wird ist aus
meiner Sicht
ein Wortbruch gegenüber der Vereinbarung
den wir nach dem Koalitionsausschuss
getroffen haben nur wenige Tage später
bot habe Entgegenkommen an vier Bereiche
sehe ich vor allem über die noch einmal
gesprochen werden kann so könnte das
Startdatum für den Heizungstausch in
Altbauten nach hinten verschoben werden
mehr technologieoffenheit etwa bei den
Pellets kommunale wärmeetzplanung soll
vorangetrieben werden und
Härtefallregelungen will Harbeck
nachbessern
Kevin Kühnert ist bei uns der
spd-generalsekretär Robert Habeck macht
jetzt seit zwei Tagen Schaulaufen erste
sehr praktische Frage wird dieses Gesetz
das Parlament erreichen und wird es das
Licht der Welt erblicken
das Licht der Welt hat es bereits
erblickt ein Vorfahren als Gesetzentwurf
so ist das üblich und ich gehe fest
davon aus dass wir in zwei Wochen dann
ist die nächste Sitzungswoche des
Deutschen Bundestages dass wir es dann
zur ersten Lesung auf der Tagesordnung
haben werden das ist die Voraussetzung
damit wir noch vor der Sommerpause so
ist das Bestreben durchkommen mit dem
Gesetz auch das halte ich nach allem was
ich so mitbekomme mittlerweile für
absolut realistisch und ich glaube auch
die Öffentlichkeit hat gemerkt viele
Einlassungen und Wortmeldungen zu dem
Thema haben sich im Tonfall und in der
Qualität deutlich verändert es wird
jetzt weniger rumgemosert und stärker
das gemacht was unser Privileg als
Abgeordnete ist nämlich an diesen
Gesetzentwürfen weiter zu arbeiten und
sie zum Besseren zu entwickeln das ist
auch gleich kritisiert worden von ihrer
Kollegin Nina schwer ist es okay für Sie
das Robert habe ich jetzt im Grunde
genommen immer noch an diesem
Gesetzentwurf herumfummelt obwohl es
jetzt eigentlich im parlamentarischen
Prozess und in der parlamentarischen
Diskussion ist Entschuldigung ja ich
würde da jetzt keinen zu großen
Widerspruch machen Robert Habeck
stellvertretend für die Bundesregierung
haben sich sehr viel Fragen in den
letzten Wochen gerichtet manche Kollegen
der FDP haben ja auch ein gewisses mit
einer gewissen Lust einen öffentliches
beheider draus gemacht mit diesen Fragen
dann finde ich es verständlich dass die
Regierung in Person des Ministers dazu
auch gegenüber den Fachleuten der
fraktionstellung beziehen möchte aber
ansonsten haben sie natürlich recht
jetzt liegt der Gesetzentwurf der
Regierung beim Parlament und sobald er
dort jetzt aufgesetzt ist dieser Entwurf
sind wir dann in den Fachausschüssen mit
den fachabgeordneten auch daran das zu
bearbeiten wir kommen zu den Details mag
scheritz ist bei uns geschätzter
Journalisten Kollege von der Zeit Herr
schieritz schön wenn die ampelpolitiker
jetzt wieder miteinander reden ist das
verlorene Vertrauen bei den Bürgern in
diesem Land genauso schnell wieder
zurück reparieren das weiß ich nicht
aber ich habe mich ein paar mal an der
bei der Beobachtung dieses Gesetz
entstanden ist schon gefragt was ist das
eigentlich für eine Regierung also es
ist ja vollkommen normal das Gesetz im
Parlament noch mal veränder verwendet
werden also die gehen nie so raus wie
sie reingehen aber dazu müssen sie sich
erstmal rein und das eine Partei in der
apokalition das verhindert hat nachdem
der Finanzminister dieser Partei
eigentlich in einer ersten Einschätzung
auch in öffentlichen Papieren zu dem
Ergebnis kamen man habe doch vorher in
den Verhandlungen mit dem
Wirtschaftsministerium recht viel schon
erreicht und dann zu sagen nee das
Gesetz ist eigentlich totalist da habe
ich nicht gehört okay was was ist
eigentlich das Ziel und deswegen glaube
ich dass der ganze Prozess wirklich
katastrophal war und auch ein Stück weit
die Legitimation von Politik befördert
hat wenn man sich fragt er was wollte er
eigentlich und insofern glaube ich wenn
das in Parlament ist dann erstmal
wichtiger Schritt geschafft und dann
beginnt ja auch die Arbeitnehmer des
Parlament ist dazu da Gesetze zu
überprüfen und auszuarbeiten 77 Fragen
100 und eine Frage Katrin Göring Eckert
ist bei uns die Vizepräsidentin des
Deutschen Bundestages sind sie die jetzt
selber schon mal durchgegangen ähm
weggeben Antworten okay wie viel eine
knappe Stunde oder so ich habe es immer
Schreck gel wissen und da steht
natürlich vieles drin was wir vorher
wussten und was auch immer diskutiert
worden ist vielleicht Kretschmann
baden-württembergischer
Ministerpräsident urgrüne 75 sagt der
Robert wollte mit dem Kopf durch die
Wand der wollte zu schnell und er wollte
mit dem Kopf durch die Wand und so
komplexe Dinge wie Heizungen kann man
nicht mit Verboten lösen
hat er recht nein und ich sag das ungern
das Winfried Kretschmann den ich ja
wirklich sehr schätze und der ja auch in
Baden-Württemberg gezeigt hat wie man
ökologische Politik so macht dass man
die Leute mitnimmt und das ist in der
Tat nicht gelungen da waren Teil davon
dass immer Sachen die in diesen
Gesetzentwurf hineingedichtet worden
sind die da gar nicht drin standen also
wir haben ja ganz oft über Verbote was
gehört die gar nicht real und so weiter
als ich weiß gar nicht jetzt noch mal
alles wiederholen das macht alle fix und
fertig genau und was für ein Kretschmann
glaube ich wo wo er recht hat ist gut
dass wir jetzt in der Situation sind wo
alle in Gang zurückschalten und sagen so
dann lass uns jetzt wirklich miteinander
reden und nicht mehr nur übereinander
und lassen sie mir aufeinander losgehen
sondern auch im Interesse der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in aller Ruhe
sagen was geht jetzt das Parlament ist
ja der hervorragendste Ort dafür da
haben wir Anhörungen da reden wir mit
ExpertInnen die Abgeordneten irgendwie
wie wir drei waren wahrscheinlich den
letzten Wochen ständig bei BürgerInnen
und Bürgerinnen bei Handwerkern bei
Verbänden
so und das ist glaube ich der
entscheidende Punkt weil da weiß man da
gibt es auch den Praxistest und der muss
jetzt gemacht werden und deswegen muss
es bitte jetzt auch ins Parlament und
alle Vorgespräche sind gut und richtig
aber dort ist der Ort ist eine sehr
besondere Kommunikation zu diesem
Kompromiss oder ein sehr merkwürdiger
Weg 18 Prozent die AFD gleich auf mit
der SPD
15%, die Grünen momentan 79% der
deutschen unzufrieden mit der Regierung
und 84% wünschen sich eine klareren Kurs
von Olaf Scholz ich weiß Umfragen sind
Momentaufnahmen ist das eine sehr
grausame Momentaufnahme das ist keine
die irgendwie komoot ist und ich bin
Thüringerin wir haben nächstes Jahr
Landtagswahlen da sieht es noch
katastrophale aus und deswegen ist die
Frage ob wir das hinbekommen ob es dann
Vertrauen gibt ob die Leute dann einfach
wissen was zu tun ist und das passiert
da in dem Augenblick wo das Gesetz
beschlossen ist deswegen ist das auch
wirklich relevant und ich kann bei allen
raten jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass nicht
mehr Verunsicherung passiert dass man
nicht mehr mit Halbwahrheiten
Unwahrheiten und Zuschreibungen kommt
sondern sich jetzt um die Sache kümmert
ist es wird alles nur teurer wenn man es
jetzt nicht macht für die Leute und das
können sie uns auf gar keinen Fall
leisten nicht fürs Klima und nicht für
die Leute sagen kommen wir gleich noch
mal die Frage was ist da eigentlich drei
Monate lang Geschehen politisch
geschehen und eben auch für die Leute in
diesem Land Mario Thaya ist bei uns
jetzt CDU-Generalsekretär sie haben
natürlich verfolgen müssen wie sehr sich
die Ampel gestritten hat FDP beste
Opposition im Land wie Friedrich Merz
sagte hat ihnen eine
Koalitionspartei schon mal so die Show
gestohlen als Opposition nee dazu haben
sie auch zu wenig Erfahrung um jetzt zu
sagen das wir haben in Deutschland
längere Zeit regiert 50 von 70 Jahren
aber zu der entscheidenden Frage ist was
bedeutet das für das Land ist eine große
Verunsicherung im Land entstanden weil
wir ja ein bestehendes Gesetz dahin
gehen verändert wurde dass die Förderung
deutlich reduziert wurde bis auf das
Thema Wärmepumpe die teuerste der aller
Technologien dass wir mit Verboten
gearbeitet haben und ich kann im
Ministerpräsidenten das ist eine etwas
verrückte Situation im
Ministerpräsidenten aus
Baden-Württemberg nur bei Pflichten er
hat höchstwahrscheinlich viel dichter an
den Menschen die Probleme wahrgenommen
dass wir jetzt mit Verboten arbeiten und
das im ersten Quartal deutlich mehr Gas
und Ölheizung verkauft wurden nämlich
doppelt so viel installiert wurden als
im Quartal davor zeigt dass diese
Verunsicherung übrigens auch dazu führt
dass nicht klimafreundlicher umgebaut
wird Münsterland genau das Gegenteil
passiert und deswegen wäre es gut wenn
wir endlich wieder zu einer von der
Verbotspolitik wegkommen hin zu einem
fördern und fordern dass die dass die
Zuschüsse auch klar sind auch da hat man
ja deutlich deutlich reduziert und dass
die sozialen Härten rausgenommen werden
aus diesem Gesetz auch das ist bislang
nicht passiert reden wir ist dieses
Gesetz jetzt sozialer geworden und ist
es technologieoffener geworden das sind
die beiden Fragen die wir logischerweise
diskutieren Siegfried großwurm ist bei
uns der BDI-Präsident Herausforderung
sie haben unter anderem nicht nur diesen
Job sondern saßen auch in der
gaspreiskommission der Bundesregierung
in diese akuten Krisenphase des letzten
Jahres und sie sind jetzt natürlich in
all diesen Besprechungen rund um dieses
Gesetz mit dabei ist das geweg und so
heißt es abgekürzt ist dieses Gebäude
Energiegesetz tatsächlich wie ein altes
Haus und man ständig überlegt ob man es
renoviert oder ob man es abreißt und
noch mal neu baut also ich bin nicht bei
all diesen Gesprächen dabei und weiß
wirklich nicht ob ich das Bedauern soll
er nicht
aber tatsächlich ist das Gesetz für mich
auch deswegen wichtig weil es zum ersten
Mal zeigt was diese Energiewende
tatsächlich und im Kern ist und das ist
Geld kostet und wir dann darüber
nachdenken müssen wie wir das
verträglich machen für alle die dabei
beteiligen jetzt wird's zum ersten Mal
fassbar das wird uns noch in ein paar
anderen Aspekten der Energiewende
passieren was mich ehrlich zu teuer es
wird Geld kosten es wird uns ärmer
machen na ja indem wir eine
Menschheitsfrage lösen genau die Frage
beantwortet man am Ende gibt es
typischerweise zwei Kandidaten die das
Zahlen
Endverbraucher und Steuerzahler dumm
wenn Sie beide sind aber das wird uns
für die Investitionen so gehen weil
damit geht es der Aufwand ja nicht weg
also wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
dass wir die Kosten die wir bisher
unterdrückt haben das ist das Konzept
der ganzen Energiewende bisher haben wir
die Kosten nicht externalisiert jetzt
zeigen wir sie auf aber müssen sie auch
zahlen was mich irritiert dabei was mich
besorgt ist dass wir dann reflexartig
sagen jetzt müssen wir es aber müssen
wir die Kosten rausnehmen müssen wir die
Kosten dämpfen die Diskussion die müssen
wir aushalten und die wird die wird echt
schwer also wer sind denn die starken
Schultern wir haben in dieser
gaskommission ganz massiv über soziale
Gerechtigkeit diskutiert und plötzlich
wurden die willenbesitzer mit Gas
beheizten Pool die waren plötzlich der
Prototyp dessen der zahlen muss ich habe
mich dann gefragt kennst du solche also
ich gebe zu ich habe dann einen gefunden
den ich kenne aber ein einziger
und ein Pool hat
wir machen uns da
glaube ich noch die Diskussion so leicht
und die Frage nach dem Heizen der
eigenen Wohnung die macht jetzt dieses
Thema zum ersten Mal griffig jetzt sehen
wir die Konsequenzen und die sind für
jeden persönlich spürbar nochmal zurück
zum politischen Prozess
wie groß sind in ihrer Erfahrung und sie
haben eine Menge davon wie groß denken
sie sind die handwerklichen Fehler die
da gemacht wurden wir diskutieren
darüber jetzt seit drei Monaten es ist
lange darüber gesprochen worden ob es
technologieoffen ist das ist festgemacht
worden an dieser wasserstofffähigkeit
von
Gasthermen also ob es morgen möglich
sein wird Gas Kraftwerke Gasthermen auch
wasserstofffähig zu betreiben das hat
uns lange beschäftigt jetzt plötzlich in
der letzten Woche reden wir über
kommunale wärmeplanungen die
Energieplanung die tatsächlich
kriegsenden sind möchte man sagen also
nur mal so ist das handwerklich für Sie
in dieser Form schon mal aufgeführt
worden ich glaube in der Kommunikation
hätte vieles besser laufen können auch
zu erklären hier gibt es eine Idee hier
gibt es ein Grundkonzept und jetzt
müssen wir darüber reden wie was im
Detail ausgestalten das hätte man
deutlicher vorneweg sagen können die die
technischen Restriktionen gibt es hier
eigentlich eine wärmeplanung und stellt
sich für dich die Frage gar nicht weil
du dem nächsten Ferne im Rohr vor deinem
Grundstück hast
wie geht es bei dem ländlichen dem Dorf
sie kommen aus Thüringen aus Nordbayern
soweit wahrscheinlich nicht voneinander
weggeboren also wenn ich bei mir
Nordbayern über die Dörfer fahre dann
muss ich gelegentlich schon genau gucken
bis ich den Haus finde wo sich die
energetische Sanierung lohnt die
allermeisten in diesen Dörfern sind so
dass sie mit einer Niedertemperatur
Heizung dort nichts gewinnen werden und
diese Aspekte hätte man früher
adressieren müssen wir fragen bevor wir
richtig einsteigen in diese inhaltlichen
Details noch mal Herr Kühnert nach Olaf
Scholz
weil die Grünen nicht nur reklamierten
dass der klimakanzler nicht mehr zu
spüren war in diesen letzten drei
Monaten und wo er den eigentlich ist und
andere reklamierten dass er wenn er
spricht zu sehr intern spricht
glauben sie da ist jetzt schon ein
Moment erreicht wo das gerade noch okay
ist wenn der Bundeskanzler sagt wir
werden zu 90% stimmen wir hier überein
und in der Strategie sind wir uns
eigentlich
ist es okay oder ist irgendwie der
Zeitpunkt schon überschritten zu sagen
wohin die SPD eigentlich will in Bezug
auf das gegen
müssen sich doch fragen wäre es
wahrscheinlicher geworden dass wir
übernächste Woche des Gesetz aufsetzen
und das vor der Sommerpause beschließen
würden dass wir die wärmewende einleiten
wenn der Bundeskanzler sich in den
letzten Wochen an dem öffentlichen
Getöse beteiligt hätte was wir zum Teil
erlebt haben er zweifelsohne dazu in der
Lage aber wir müssen doch Kompromisse am
Ende finden und was der Bundeskanzler zu
keiner Zeit getan hat ist auch nur ein
bisschen Luft an die Frage rankommen zu
lassen ob diese Regierung den Anspruch
hat über das Gebäude Energiegesetz die
wärmewende in Deutschland voranzutreiben
während andere die Diskussion aufgemacht
haben ob es nicht doch sinnvoll wäre den
CO2-Preis ins Unermessliche zu steigern
und den Leuten einfach 300 € für die
Tonne CO2 vor die Füße zu schmeißen und
dann stellen die das schon alleine um
ist er da auf Kurs geblieben und das
einfach bei unserem Koalitionsvertrag
geblieben ich bin ja ein bisschen als
Zeitzeuge hier ich habe für die SPD die
Arbeitsgruppe Bauen und Wohnen geleitet
in den Koalitionsverhandlungen genau
dort haben wir über das Thema Gebäude
Energiegesetz besprochen und haben
reingeschrieben knapp 2025 damals noch
soll das gelten man hätte sich
anderthalb Jahre damit beschäftigen
können also ich ziehe mir jede Kritik an
zu sagen wir hatten früher eine bessere
Kommunikation einsteigen können ich
erlaube mir aber auch zu sagen
vielleicht hätte es letztes Jahr auch
eine Sendung weniger zum Thema Panzer
getan wo man dann sich mal unterhalten
hätte können über die Frage der
wärmewende in Deutschland das war kein
Staatsgeheimnis sondern es stand immer
in Koalitionsverträgen und Beschlüssen
der Koalition ich finde immer toll wenn
den Medien dann genau ich will jetzt
nicht Medien irgendwie verteidigen ich
will nur sagen es wäre wichtiger dass
die Politik erinnert hätte dass es diese
vor dieses Vorhaben im Koalitionsvertrag
wir haben schon beide eine Verantwortung
wir haben beide eine Verantwortung und
jetzt gehe ich mal auf das ein was sie
inhaltlich gesagt haben nicht nur da
draußen haben offensichtlich Menschen
diese Thesen gehabt sondern katrin
Göring-Eckardt fand dass der
Bundeskanzler ein bisschen mehr hätte
liefern können schauen Sie mal ein
Bundeskanzler muss sich an die Spitze
des Kampfes gegen die Klimakrise stellen
anstatt zu bremsen
Katrin Göring ja also denkt sich jetzt
auch niemand aus das ist eine
koalitionsinterne Kritik am
Bundeskanzler
nicht der lauerste lauteste Maxe haben
sie gesagt soll Olaf Scholz sein noch
mal die Frage hätte er mehr agieren
müssen in dieser Krise wenn das Gesetz
jetzt am Ende kommt und danach sieht es
aus dann ist die Strategie die richtige
gewesen weil sie hat eben den
gewünschten weg und Erfolg nicht
verhindert man hätte sich anders in die
Debatte lauter ordinärer einbringen
können als er das getan hat aber er ist
eben derjenige der er im Hintergrund an
der Lösungsfindung arbeitet und dafür
sorgt dass die Ziele des beschlossenen
und rechtsgültigen klimaschutzgesetzes
in Deutschland nämlich bis 2045
klimaneutral zu sein und die jährlichen
Ziele zu erreichen der das vorantreibt
und die Zahlen sind eindeutig ein
Drittel unserer Emissionen in
Deutschland gehen auf den gebäudessektor
zurück das meiste davon resultiert aus
der Art wie wir unsere Gebäude beheizen
und wie wir das Wasser warm machen was
wir nutzen insofern gibt es keine
Klimaneutralität ohne die wärmewende und
Sie werden kein Zitat eines
Sozialdemokraten aus den letzten Wochen
finden dass dem in irgendeiner Weise
widerspricht wir sind Team wärmewende
und zwar über den Weg des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes ganz klar ich habe sie
haben Sie sich geirrt Frau Göring und
zwar um Olaf Scholz noch mal ein
bisschen zögerlich ich sage nicht dass
er nicht kommuniziert aber doch eher
zögerlich war in der Verteidigung dieses
Gesetzes weil diese Koalition ja oder
Teile der Kollektion angetreten sind
sozusagen wir machen Klimawende aber ihr
werdet es nicht spüren das machen wir
dann investieren wir und dann bauen wir
Elektroautos und alles bleibt wie es ist
ähm und alles wird gut und jetzt das
geil hat der Russ von vollkommen Recht
jetzt stellt sich immer raus und man
wird es spüren und es wird Geld kosten
und Klimaschutz ist uns sozial für sich
genommen und kostet Geld und sozusagen
dieser diese Illusion dann wenn man das
gut Klimaschutz und dann gibt's auch den
Leuten besser und dann löst sich alles
jedes Problem
in diesem Gesetz und deswegen ist es
glaube ich schon sehr zentral auch die
Lehren daraus zu ziehen dass man
vielleicht auch ehrlicher kommuniziert
zu sagen das ist einfach eine Aufgabe
ist eine menschheitsaufgabe und wenn ich
zehn Milliarden in Klimaschutz
investiere kann ich mir davon keine was
weiß ich kaufen keine Kaugummis oder
irgendwas und diesen trade auf diese
dieses diese Zielkonflikte wird halt
jetzt deutlich und der ist natürlich
sozialdemokratisch nicht so schön und
oder schwieriger zu kommunizieren
vielleicht als für andere Parteien ja
genau unsere Aufgabe an der Stelle zu
arbeiten weil der Bundeskanzler kann ja
genauso wie wir alle die Umfragen sehen
und das ist ja gar nicht unbedingt nötig
einer Mehrheit erstmal noch zu erklären
dass wir eine wärmewende brauchen also
alle Umfragen jetzt Politbarometer
letzte Woche zeigen ganz klar die
Mehrheit der Leute sagt wir brauchen die
wärmewende die Mehrheit hat sogar im
politikometer gesagt sie sind dafür das
ab nächsten Jahr keine fossilen Heizung
mehr eingebaut werden das heißt der
Streitpunkt der gesellschaftliche und
das aus guten Grund ist die Frage des
Lasten Ausgleichs am Ende wer hat es wie
stark zu spüren das ist Kosten
verursacht und das irgendwer die tragen
muss und es werden keine grünen Männchen
sein ist logisch aber wir diskutieren
zwei Fragen Frau Göring-Eckardt erstens
hat der Bundeskanzler die Grünen im
Stich gelassen nein es geht ja nicht um
den Stich lassen sondern es geht ja auch
nicht darum dass das jetzt ein grünes
Anliegen ist das habe ich auch gesagt in
dem gleichen Interview ist ja nicht so
dass die wärmewende oder die Bewältigung
der Klimakrise soweit wird das noch
können das ist irgendwie eine grüne
Spezialaufgabe ist und es ist eine
Aufgabe der gesamten Regierung ich würde
sagen einer konstruktiven Opposition ich
habe das gesagt weil ich fand in dieser
kritischen Situation wo die Menschen
merken es geht wirklich an das
Privateste es geht an die Wohnung es
geht an das Haus es geht an das wo ich
zu Hause bin das ist ja was anderes als
wenn man sagt irgendwie ganz weit weg da
bauen die Leitungen oder Windräder oder
was auch immer und in diesem Augenblick
hätte ich mir sehr gewöhnt dass der von
sich selbst ausgerufene Klima kannst du
sagt leute das ist jetzt wirklich ernst
wir müssen das gemeinsam machen er hat
es übrigens zwei Tage später auch getan
an dem Wochenende nach diesem du
wahrscheinlich nicht bei X gesagt habe
sondern aus eigener Einsicht da bin ich
ganz fest von überzeugt aber natürlich
ja wirklich so aber ich glaube dieses
dass Menschen spüren das ist jetzt bei
uns das ist jetzt bei uns zu Hause das
ist was kostet und dass die Frage ist
wie wir das sozial gestalten aber nicht
im Nachgang das ist mir noch ganz
wichtig zu sagen ich glaube der Fehler
war wirklich das nicht von Anfang an
überlegt worden ist das ist eine soziale
Frage wenn wir nichts machen dann wird
es richtig teuer für die Leute und es
müssen sich eben auch alle Leute leisten
können die müssen dabei sein können die
müssen mitmachen können ich bin ehrlich
gesagt so ein bisschen gar kein Fan von
Härtefällen weil Härtefall heute heißt
Sie müssen am Ende trotzdem mehr
bezahlen das ist gar nicht wünschenswert
und deswegen ist die Frage kriegen wir
so hin dass alle mitmachen können und
vielleicht sogar Lust darauf haben Teil
dieses Projektes zu sein von dem wir
auch zeigen können was wir können als
Land gemeinsam hängen bleibt vor
geringen Eckert er habe gelegt vor und
die SPD und die FDP machen das Ganze
dann
Praxis tauglich nee das ist nicht der
Fall Herr Habig hat vorgelegt zum
Beispiel eine einkommensstaffelung von
Anfang an er hat ein Gesetz gemacht was
ja sehr detailliert war aber er hat auch
nicht gesagt das ist es jetzt schluss
aus Ende sondern hat gesagt das ist das
fürs parlamentarische Verfahren darüber
will ich jetzt diskutieren und ich
glaube es gibt wenige Politikerinnen und
Politiker die in der Lage sind zu sagen
okay dann lass uns genau darüber
nachdenken was können wir noch besser
machen was können wir anders machen wir
haben viel über Ost und West geredet wie
ist der Unterschied ja in Ostdeutschland
sind zwar viel mehr Häuser saniert in
den letzten 30 Jahren trotzdem haben die
Leute in massiv geringeres Einkommen und
schon gar kein Vermögen halb so viel wie
in Westdeutschland diese Fragen haben
wir in den letzten Wochen diskutiert es
auch richtig das muss auch sein es soll
auch niemand denken das ist jemand in
der geheimstube sagt so machen wir es
und dann kommt das Klimakrise bewältigen
ist teuer wäre noch teuer wenn wir es
nicht machen würden und ich möchte gerne
dass alle dabei sein können das
Verstehen und wie gesagt vielleicht auch
am Ende Lust aber am Ende gibt es
vielleicht eben auch eine technische
Frage bevor wir zu den sozialen Dingen
muss man ja erst mal Fragen gibt es
alternativen zu der wärmewende und das
ist neben dem Fall reichen ja
ausführlich gewendet worden ob es
technologieoffen genug ist Herr ich
wollte das bei Ihnen noch mal
hinterfragen lange ist darüber
gesprochen worden von der FDP besonders
dass wir eben auch Gasleitungen offen
halten am Leben halten sollen um sie
wasserstofffähig zu machen diese
Wasserstoff readiness ist ja Ergebnis
dieses Koalitionsausschusses gewesen
sogar ist diese Frage in ihren Augen
final beantwortet ist das klug oder ist
es nicht klug zu sagen okay der Staat
konzentriert sich diese Regierung
konzentriert sich jetzt mehr oder
weniger auf wärmepunkt ich finde das
ausgesprochen unverantwortlich gehandelt
wurde weil sehr viel Verunsicherung im
Land entstanden ist und weil
beispielsweise in der
einkommensstaffelung so ist dass man 80%
Förderung bekommen wenn man 20.000 €
verdient wer da noch ein Haushalt bei
diesem Einkommen da stellt man sich die
Frage
Schicksal diese soziale Frage wirklich
lösen dein richtig wäre doch gewesen
erstens hatten wir ein bestehendes
Klimaschutzgesetz und das gilt auch
heute noch dieses Klimaschutzgesetz und
danach war die Förderung höher und die
Bereitschaft sich dieser wärmewende zu
stellen war von den privaten Haushalten
und den Unternehmen deutlich höher als
es jetzt der Fall ist weil wir ein
anderes Prinzip hatten nicht Ideologie
und Einengung auf wenige Technologien
sondern fördern und fördern aus unserer
Sicht wäre es erforderlich zuerst eine
wärmeplanung zu machen dass das Gesetz
jetzt hinten dran kommt ist der falsche
Weg zuerst muss man diese
wärmeplanungsfrage stellen wenn ich
diese wärmeplanungsfrage habe habe ich
die Frage von kommunalen Netzen die
Frage was ist fern damit tauglich wir
werden nachher höchstwahrscheinlich aus
Dänemark ein paar Beispiele hören wo es
gelingen kann aber sie bringen jetzt
dieses Gesetz zur wärmeplanung danach
ein wo es Gebäude Energiegesetz und
Energieeffizienz gesetzt gerade in einem
völligen durcheinander ist die Menschen
wissen überhaupt nicht mehr im Land
Bescheid was eine Rolle spielen sollen
sie sehen nur Vervielfachung für
fünffachung der Kosten und es ist ähn
wie beim verbrennerverbot es werden mehr
Benziner und mehr Diesel verkauft als
noch bevor er Robert Habeck
Verantwortung hatte war die Menschen
wieder auf die alte Technologie gehen
wir haben Kohlekraftwerke wieder
eingestellt weil die Kernkraft
ideologisch bedingt abgeschaltet wurde
und wir haben jetzt im Gebäudebereich
genau das gleiche und deswegen ist
dieses Gesetz und auch diese
Herangehensweise aus unserer Sicht die
falsche
Werbeplanung haben
diese Technologie
zweite muss man dann schauen was ist in
den einzelnen Gebäuden möglich und da
brauchen wir deutlich mehr
technologieoffenheit pellets sind eine
ökologisch sinnvolle Lösung nicht
überall im Land aber zum Beispiel im
ländlichen Raum in Bayern ist das
sicherlich eine vernünftige Lösung auch
CO2 neutral umsetzbar wir haben das
Thema Geothermie nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt die Wasserstoff
übrigens überhaupt nicht entgehen
überall eingesetzt werden meine Fraktion
setzt sich dafür ein dass wir das auch
im Neubau weiter machen das ist aber ein
vergleichsweise kleiner Teil also die
Verunsicherung und das Durcheinander was
sie beklagen da geht ein Teil auf
unseren Deckel ihre Parteifreunde haben
aber schon auch mit einem großen Genuss
in den letzten Wochen dazu beigetragen
dass die Leute auch nicht mehr wussten
wo vorne
auf die Fehler hinweist ist die Aufgabe
der Opposition und gleichzeitig stellen
und gleichzeitig haben wir in jeder
Parlamentssitzung in jeder
parlamentssitzungswoche neue Vorschläge
diskutiert wir haben seit Ende März
unsere Vorschläge Andreas Jung und ich
auf den Tisch gelegt wir haben das im
Präsidium unser Partei beschlossen wir
haben jede Woche über unterschiedliche
Dinge gesprochen über Pellets haben wir
gesprochen über Wasserstoff haben wir
gesprochen über Kernfusion haben wir
gesprochen wir haben im Parlament diese
technologieoffene Diskussion angestoßen
und deutlich gemacht wo sind die Fehler
in dieser Regierung was macht Robert
habe da falsch und ja der Kanzler führt
überhaupt gar nicht er versteckt sich er
versteckt sich hinter den anderen das
Kanzleramt hat überhaupt keine die Feder
für eine Rolle mehr in diesem ganzen
Verfahren es ist ja nicht nur dieses
Gesetz es sind weit über 70 Gesetze die
da derzeitig zwischen den Ministerinnen
und hergeschoben werden die nicht
beraten werden und diese Verunsicherung
im Land führt natürlich auch dazu dass
viele Menschen so verunsichert sind dass
sie am Ende glauben die politischen
Ränder sind nur noch das was ihnen hilft
genau wir haben wir wollen ja was
verstehen wir wollen verstehen wie
Deutschland momentan eigentlich heizt
ich weiß nicht ob sie sich diese Frage
schon mal gestellt haben oder eine diese
101 Fragen die die FDP gestellt hat auch
diese wäre gucken Sie doch bitte
freundlicherweise mal gemeinsam mit mir
und unseren Gästen diese Übersicht an
knappe 50% ist Gas knappe 25 % der
Heizungen in Deutschland sind Öl dann
kommen immerhin 14% Wärmepumpen Quatsch
Fernwärme Entschuldigung drei Prozent
nur Wärmepumpen dann gibt's noch Strom
und sonstiges und bei diesen sonstigen
übrigens festhalten sind jetzt die
Pellets dabei und die Solarthermie dabei
das heißt nur damit wir es verstehen
Herr Kühnert wenn jetzt Robert Habeck
die Pellets annotiert wenn Sie jetzt von
den Pellets reden dann können wir das
selbst verdoppeln dann wird uns das
unser Hauptproblem nicht lösen weil
eigentlich müssen wir ja von den 50%
Gas weg und von 25% Öl Weg so also warum
erzählen die Kunde warum erzählen sie
jetzt auch was von Pellets wenn wir
jeder maximal zwei Prozent im also wo
sollte das Holz auch herkommen wo sollen
die Pellets herkommen damit wir damit
jetzt eine neue Technologie ich habe
deshalb gerade von Pellets gesprochen um
einfach der falsch Behauptung dass der
Gesetzentwurf gar nichts mit Pellets
vorsehen würde so widersprechen auch
wenn es in Prozent wenig sind sind das
einige hunderttausend Haushalte wo jetzt
Leute zu Hause sitzen und sagen dann nur
was macht denn die Ampel da und den
wollte ich gerne signalisieren wir
wollen nicht dass die sich von ihrer
Pelletheizung verabschieden sondern die
dürfen Sie gerne
aber die jetzigen Regeln für Pellets
sind so hochgesetzt dass sie faktisch
nicht mehr umsetzbar sind weil man dazu
dann noch eine Wärmepumpe mit
installieren muss und das macht es für
den Einzelnen so teuer dass es die
Pelletheizung nicht mehr geben wird
entschuldigung aber ich fand dieses
Tortendiagramm
eine Sicht die ist wichtig aber die
zweite die wir dazulegen muss ist in
welcher Granularität machen müsste was
ich nie verstanden habe in der ganzen
Diskussion ist wieso wir zum Beispiel
öffentliche Gebäude erstmal ausnehmen
aus diesem Gebäude Energiegesetz und
nicht genau umgekehrt vorgehen und sagen
was sind denn die großen Emittenten ja
und dann können wir am Ende über das
Einfamilienhaus egal ob im Landkreis
Coburg oder im Landkreisen gerne reden
aber lass uns doch bei den großen
Trümmern anfangen und wenn ich dann höre
aber öffentliche Gebäude nehmen wir
erstmal aus wie soll das nicht
Glaubwürdigkeit bei einem privaten
Hauseigentümer von dem alten Haus war
dann wir tun doch viel mehr fürs Klima
nachdem wir die großen Emittenten im
Sinne eines paretodiagramms mal angehen
und ja große Gebäudekomplexe die man
sanieren muss die man idealerweise
seriell saniert schnell saniert und
konsequent umstellt ja aber auch
öffentliche Gebäude die wir umstellen
und hinten an der Schlange können wir
uns dann auch noch über das
Einfamilienhaus in coburgau wir sind im
Grunde da auch noch mal bei dieser
fernwärmediskussion also warum reden wir
jetzt erst in der letzten Woche über
diese kommunalen fernwärmeplanungen das
ist ein separates Gesetz da sagt Robert
habe jetzt Herr schiritz er möchte es
synchron verhandelt Wissen von Frau
Gallwitz müsste das nicht vorher
passieren fragen wir das bevor wir zu
den öffentlichen Gebäuden kommen also
natürlich braucht man die Informationen
und braucht die Logik dieser
fernbewertung sonst gibt es ja keinen
Sinn aber das man kann das ja auch
innerhalb des Gesetzentwurfs rein
verlinken und muss deswegen nicht den
Gesetzgebungsprozess starten also man
hätte auch ganz normal sagen können
letzte Woche so jetzt kommt es im
Bundestag und im Rahmen einer Beratungen
sozusagen schauen wir dass wir die
Verbindung zu entfernt werden wir
hinkriegen die ist natürlich ist die
inhaltlich sinnvoll aber wenn ich das
darf ich habe noch eine Frage der
Entscheid aber ich habe es wirklich
einfach nicht verstanden worin die
alternativen der Union bestehen also
klar Kernfusion um 20 Jahren oder 30
Jahren gibt es vielleicht ein kleines
radarchen das dann läuft CO2-Preis haben
wir jetzt schon gehört wird super teuer
das heißt nämlich Öl Gas Benzin alles
wird sehr viel teurer also mir ist nicht
klar wie sie dann denn dieses Dilemma
dass man die Leute dann eben nicht
belastet lösen sollen klar man kann
sagen man schraubt die Förderung hoch
das kostet dann noch ein paar Milliarden
wir haben eine Schuldenbremse wir haben
einen Haushalt also irgendwo muss ja die
muss das Geld oder müssen ihre
Ressourcen herkommen um die um diese
Ziele zu erreichen wenn es nicht über
diese ordnungsrechtlichen Maßnahmen
ich verstehe es wirklich nicht die Frage
ist mit welcher Grund ist immer die
gehen sie rein gehen sie mit verbieten
und verboten denn das System ran oder
gehen Sie mit Förderung daran und wenn
es richtig gemacht worden wäre wäre
zunächst die wärmeplanung das richtige
Instrument gewesen wenn sie sich den
wasserstoffplan ist von Robert habe
Fernsehen sehen sie dass dort eben nicht
die Leitung beplant werden wo
Wasserstoff transportiert werden kann wo
regenerative Energien die momentan still
stehen weil sie nicht in der Lage sind
umgewandelt zu werden in Wasserstoff
weil sie nicht gespeichert werden können
weil sie den Strompreis hochtreiben dass
wir diese Frage der wärmelnetze zuerst
klären dass wir dann über kommunale
wärmeverbünde sprechen dann wissen wo
haben wir die wo haben wir die großen
Verbräuche und dass wir bei dem Frage
der verbrauche nicht nur die Heizung
sondern auch die Gebäudehülle mit
betrachten und dann daraus die
Entscheidung treffen und das ganze dann
mit Förderinstrumenten wie der
heizungsumbauprämie die wir in unserer
Regierungszeit als wir miteinander
Verantwortung hatten eingeführt haben
die ja besser funktioniert hat als der
derzeitige Streit der bei den Menschen
große Sorgen und Ängste auslöst und
zurückführt zu einer alten Technologie
wo ich teile das ist gefährlich ist dass
man mit dieser Politik dazu führt dass
die Menschen sich eine Technologien
wieder einbauen die an on the long way
für sie so teuer ist und Sorgen machen
kann was heute viele noch nicht
beurteilen können
also ganz viel aufgezählt und es muss
dann immer noch einmal Wasserstoff
gesagt werden obwohl wir alle gemeinsam
wissen das Heizen mit Wasserstoff für
ein 0,0 irgendwas Prozent sein wird es
kommt mir immer so vor als auch meine
ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nur
unterbrechen Entschuldigung weil wir
auch einen kleinen Schnipsel aus einer
sagenumwobenen Koalitionsausschuss
Sitzung aufgehoben haben in der dabei
Christian Lindner Pressekonferenz in der
Christian Lindner hinterher folgendes
sagte Festhalten der Finanzminister
außerdem sollen fossiler Heizungen
weiterhin zugelassen werden die
Wasserstoff oder grüne Gase ready sind
sofern es eine entsprechende Planung für
das Gasnetz gibt es wird keine
Austauschpflicht geben für bestehende
Heizungen sondern lediglich Vorgaben für
neu eingebaute Heizungen
das hat übrigens genauso auch Olaf
Scholz gesagt ich will sie jetzt nicht
verwirren und ich will Ihnen auch nicht
mich auch gar nicht gar nicht ist darf
auch Wasserstoff sein es ist nur nicht
realistisch dass man mit Wasserstoff
etwas löst das wollte ich sagen weil das
ganz wenig sein wird so technologieoffen
sind wir das ist gemacht worden aber er
hat wenn ich jetzt einmal genau das
passiert was eben auch gesagt was es war
Kernfusion eben gesprochen worden wenn
Sie mit dem Vorschein in Greifswald
sprechen sagen sie wir sind in zehn
Jahren in der Lage das umzusetzen wenn
Sie mit jemandem wenn sie mit denen wenn
sie mit denjenigen sprechen die über die
über die Fernwärmeleitung sprechen sagen
sie die Speicherung von regenerativen
Energien und die Umwandlung in
Wasserstoff ermöglicht enorme Mengen an
Wärme für Fernwärmenetze zum Beispiel
für Berlin oder für Leipzig oder andere
große Städte und das haben sie in ihren
Planungen völlig eingeengt auf das Thema
Wärmepumpe einmal über die Sache reden
die sie vorschlagen und wie sie es
vorschlagen ich bin wirklich vehement
dafür das wird das mit der wärmeplanung
machen parallel machen das muss sein wir
werden wir sind uns einig dass das vorne
weggehört hätte und jetzt können Sie
einmal kurz Pause machen dann bin ich
dann ist auch für die Stimme viel besser
so
wir können müssen über wärmeplanung
reden geht nicht anders müssen wir
parallel machen zu dem anderen ganz ganz
klar und ein deutlich sie tun jetzt so
als ob sie so weitermachen könnten wie
die letzten 16 Jahre das Ergebnis haben
wir jetzt deswegen müssen wir nämlich so
schnell sein sie sagen dann machen wir
erstmal das und dann warten wir mal was
passiert und vielleicht noch ein Foto
ergeben
dürfen wir brauchen das gleichzeitig es
muss in einander es muss doch wir machen
es weil die Wärme
da und die Kommunen wenn man mit denen
redet die sagen na klar wir stellen uns
längst darauf ein dass auch wärmeplanung
gemacht werden muss dass die Leute
wissen ja wir haben ein Nahwärmenetz wir
haben entfernt Wärme Netz aber dass wir
nicht noch mal bitte nicht noch mal
wieder auf die Bremse treten das geht zu
lassen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger und es
geht zu lassen
einfach mal Kevin kühne gehabt in den
letzten vier Herr Kühnert und dann ist
der Ruß vom dran ich möchte gerne
verstehen was sie glauben dass die
Menschen ihnen sagen die morgen eine
Wärmepumpe einbauen und so ein
ratterndes lustiges Ding an ihrem Balkon
haben und übermorgen erfahren dass es
eine kommunale Fernwärme Lösung gibt
oder Nahwärme Lösung muss das was wir
gerade gesagt haben nicht vorträglich
passieren muss vorher nicht über die
größeren Emittenten nachgedacht werden
Ehemann 40 Millionen Deutsche mit ja
nicht nur einem materiellen und
finanziellen Aufwand sondern eine
Bürokratie und irgendwann vielleicht
mehr Subvention ja absolut wir können
jetzt aber nicht den heizungsaustausch
die nächsten 10 Monate anhalten allein
schon weil immer mal wieder eine Heizung
kaputt geht den Leuten kann ich ja nicht
sagen wir warten jetzt bis Anfang
nächsten Jahres so genau im Moment
werden übrigens auch mehr Wärmepumpen
eingebaut alleine 100.000 verteilt
dieses Jahres absolut steigende Zahlen
ist bei vielen Menschen da wo es passt
sehr gut anschließen gucken wir einmal
ins nächste Jahr weiter der
Gesetzentwurf sogar so wie er jetzt
schon von den Ministerien gekommen ist
sieht Übergangsfristen vor einerseits um
beispielsweise eine gebrauchte
heizungübergang erstmal nutzen zu können
aber natürlich auch
genau und natürlich auch mit
Berücksichtigung dann jetzt auf das was
wir bei der kommunalen wärmeplanung
machen die kommunale wärmeplanung wenn
sie dieses Jahr durch ist das was Frau
geibelshaus kommt wird zunächst für
große und dann für immer kleiner
werdende Städte
Zeiträume in den nächsten Jahren
vorsehen bis wann die ihre kommunale
wärmeplanung machen müssen was ist eine
kommunale wärmeplanung da guckt man sich
an was sind die wärmebedarfe vor Ort was
sind bisher die Wärme Quellen und wie
ökologisch oder nicht sind die und wo
können wir noch Wärme herholen Abwasser
Industrie Abwärme Rechenzentren Flüsse
Meere so wie es in Dänemark jetzt z.B
gemacht wird das nimmt man zusammen dann
schaut man wie viel Masse an Wärme kommt
da zusammen und wie viele Haushalte
können damit bespeiten dann unterteilt
man die Stadt vor Ort in bestimmte
Gebiete angeschlossen und wir werden sie
es nicht doch genau so wird es ja noch
gar nicht das Gesetz aber genauso wird
es am Ende passieren und so lange wie
die Kommune das vor Ort nicht festgelegt
hat jetzt keine Zeit gehabt aber die
Frage müssen so ein bisschen auch Herrn
Freunden nicht aber nach 16 Jahren zu
kommen und hier ein bunten blumenstrich
in der jetzigen Regierung ist es nicht
mehr ich möchte gerne verstehen ob die
wasserstofffähigen
Gaskraftwerke die wasserstofffähigen
Gasthermen
ausgedacht sind ein Fake sind der
wahnsinnig
kleinen unrealistisch zu teuer
Champagner der Energiewende sagen die
Grünen ist oder ob es eine ob es
realistisch ist den Wasserstoff ich
frag's weil 50% der Bürger dieses Landes
haben eine Gastherme und die möchten
jetzt gerne wissen was daraus wird und
hier ist die ganz praktische Frage an
den Ingenieuren wie realistisch ist es
funktioniert ist technisch also über die
Technik mache ich mir keine Sorgen
worüber ich mir Sorgen mache ist wir
haben kein Energiekonzept wir haben
jetzt ein Tisch über einen warme Konzept
geredet das wir brauchen bevor wir dem
einzelnen hausseigentümer vorschreiben
was denn passieren soll wir müssen über
einen Energiekonzept reden wir haben
Absichten ganz tolle das wird zum
Beispiel x Prozent unsere Strombedarfs
aus decken wir akzeptieren also Robert
habe heute
eine Nachrichten also hierher gefahren
bin wir akzeptieren dass wir
backupraftwerke brauchen für diesen
kalten November Abend die dunkelflaute
genau und dann bauen wir Gaskraftwerke
und jetzt fragt sich der Ingenieur
technisch habe ich angeschaut also ich
weiß dass unsere Ingenieure das können
aber wer plant die wer genehmigt die wer
baut die wer stellt die hin mit welchem
Treibstoff wir haben finanziert das
ganze
Werke die sind dann wasserstofffähig und
die brauchen wir um diese stromlöcke ab
20 30 zusammen eine Wärmequelle mit
ihrer Abwärme zum Beispiel mal wissen
wie viele Stunden werden die den laufen
um dann zu wissen ob ich mit dieser
Abwärme vernünftig speichern und dann
heizen kann oder nicht also wenn wir
nicht ein Gesamtkonzept jetzt auf die
Beine stellen und zwar sehr konkret wo
steht was und wer baut es für welche
Unternehmen wer bezahlt das wer betreibt
das und was kostet es dann doch dann
wird doch ein Kleinigkeiten haben okay
also nochmal Wasserstoff kostet
einschließlich bitte nicht nur in der
Insel Deutschland denken zu welchen
Kosten können wir den Energie
importieren ich glaube das immer langsam
endlich alle beieinander dass
Deutschland nicht energieautark werden
wird und dann muss man die mal kurz den
Blick heben und sagen ich kenne ja
Regionen in der Welt da kann ich die
Kilowattstunde Strom für einen Cent
erzeugen am 16 KV Knoten als am ersten
Umspannwerk dahinter die gleichen Länder
bauen elektrolyseeinheiten lassen die
von deutschen Firmen bauen also
scheinbar können die deutschen
Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure was und
sagen dann sagt mir was ihr wollt was
ihr denn von mir kaufen wollt solange
wir dieses nicht mal durch dekliniert
haben finde ich ziemlich mutig zu sagen
ich weiß was welche Energieträger wo in
Deutschland und durch welches Netz das
ist doch gar nicht gibt den Kosten
werden die sie haben und trotzdem noch
mal nachgefragt das heißt dass sie
glauben dass wenn wir jetzt so viel auf
den Strom setzen und eigentlich all
unsere ökologischen Prozesse egal ob es
das Heizen oder ob es der Verkehr
anderes ist wenn wir das alles
verstromen oder mit Strom lösen wollen
dass dann erst recht auch für die
Industrie der stromknapp wird ich glaube
das ist kein Gegeneinander keine Frage
von Industrie vasus privaten Verbraucher
wir haben heute eine Situation dass wir
irgendwo zwischen 20 und 25 Prozent
unseres Energiebedarfs mit Strom Decken
heißt mindestens drei Viertel anders wir
haben es gerade bei der Wärme gesehen
das kommen gerade die 75% raus das heißt
wir brauchen ein Energiekonzept noch mal
und nicht nur ein warme Konzept
technisch ich habe die Gasturbine
gesehen ich weiß mit welchen
technologischen Möglichkeiten man
Wasserstoff in
Berlin kann man sich das anschauen es
gibt aber auf der Welt nach meiner
Kenntnis nein in der westlichen Welt
China Überblick ich nicht aber ich habe
heute noch mal bisschen telefoniert es
gibt drei Unternehmen auf der Welt die
eine wasserstofffähige Gasturbine bauen
können
jetzt müsste ich gerne wer von den
dreien baut wo an welchen 35 Standorten
in Deutschland diese Kraftwerke damit
wenigstens die 25 Gigawatt die Robert
habe ich genannt hat
zustande kommt den solange die nicht
stehen werden wir Kohle verfeuern mit
all dem CO2 footprints hat und das
machen wir seit Monaten und Monaten
immer mehr und immer mehr
das hat nicht nur
nein
nicht das wissen sie auch sondern das
liegt natürlich auch daran weil auf
andere Technologien momentan verzichtet
wurde und weil Kernkraft vorzeitig
abgeschaltet wurde was nicht notwendig
gewesen wäre wenn man sie bis Ende 10
Millionen Haushalte sind mit den drei
Kernkraftwerken versorgt bei gewesen und
sie haben voreilig abgeschaltet und
Kohlekraft hochgefahren wenn sie das
nicht ideologisch bezeichnen weiß ich
nicht was ist dann ist wir würden
tatsächlich ist er jetzt schon so oft
erwähnt unbedingt mal schauen wollen wie
es die anderen machen wir haben eine
Journalisten Kollegen bei uns der aus
Dänemark kommt und wir sind dankbar
dafür dass die gleich mit ihm reden
können und schauen uns ganz kurz vorher
noch mal an hier sind die denen wie sie
es machen
die Dänen haben den Abschied von Öl und
Gasheizungen längst eingeleitet sie sind
schon seit 2013 in Neubauten verboten
gleichzeitig mussten die Verbraucher
eine Abgabe auf fast alle
heizbrennstoffe Bezahlen von der Gebühr
befreit waren Wärmepumpen in Dänemark
wurden zuletzt umgerechnet auf 1.000
Haushalte 5 mal mehr Wärmepumpen
installiert als in Deutschland
noch besser Dänemarks Fernwärmenetz
knapp 65% der Haushalte sind daran
angeschlossen und es wird weiter
ausgebaut in esberg speist eine der
größten Wärmepumpen der Welt demnächst
ihre Wärme ins kommunale Netze ein die
Technik kommt von man aus Deutschland
matt hier Sonne ist bei uns und wird uns
jetzt erklären wie die Dänen es gemacht
haben dänischer Journalist von Dobler
informasion 2013 haben wir gelernt
Dänemark schafft Öl und Gas Heizung in
Neubauten ab 2016 in Altbauten wie haben
sie das den Bürgern vermittelt wie wie
wurde das abgepuffert also erstmal muss
man ja wissen dass Dänemark ist ein Land
wo zwei Drittel der Haushalte am
fernwärmen jetzt angeschlossen sind und
das macht natürlich ein riesen
Unterschied auch für den Übergang und
die die Übergangsfristen und
auslauffristen waren auch daran gebunden
ob man tatsächlich Zugang hatte zu einem
Fernwärme Anschluss so dass schon im
vorab aber natürlich hat man genau wie
es hier diskutiert werden und wie wie es
jetzt in Deutschland geplant wird auch
mit Stick und Cars also mit mit Peitsche
gearbeitet und mit
auf Hochdeutsch und
gleichzeitig auch mit starken
Subventionen das ist klar und es ist
auch nicht so dass das streitfrei
abgelaufen ist in in Dänemark also klar
hat es da auch also das sind die Bäume
auch nicht in den Himmel gewachsen und
vor allem Streit und trotzdem ist ja die
Frage wie plant man so etwas und wer
plant das Dänemark ist kleiner es gibt
auch weniger Menschen und trotzdem sind
sie uns natürlich schon 20 Jahre voraus
in dem was sie vor zehn Jahren begonnen
haben welche Institution welche
Organisation hat geplant für das gesamte
Land und dann automatisch auch für die
Quartiere für die also für die Viertel
der Städte und also dann müssen wir
erstmal noch weiter zurück springen in
die Geschichte weil wie gesagt das hängt
ja an an diese große Verbreitung der
Ferne Netze ab und das passiert nicht
nach der Ölkrise sozusagen als Antwort
auf die Ölkrise in den 70er Jahren in 79
hat man
wärmeversorgungsgesetz gemacht und da
hat man sozusagen die Kommunen in
Dänemark gezwungen
wärmepläne zu machen oder vorzulegen
haben die auch gemacht und seitdem ist
sind dann die die fernwärmätze in den
magst sozusagen von von unten gewachsen
das heißt auch die haben ganz andere
Legitimität gekriegt und das heißt auch
dass man mit mit diesem Abschied von von
Öl und Gasheizung hat man natürlich ganz
andere Instrumenten in der Hand gehabt
und wie gesagt das war nichts drin vor
allem in ländlichen Regionen haben viele
auch gesagt das kann doch nicht sein
mein Öl Heizung läuft hier seit
Jahrzehnten und jetzt jetzt sitze hier
was durch und klar das da ist die
Antwort im Moment wie wir auch sagen im
einspannen ja es ist natürlich die
Wärmepumpe weil die ergänzen sich
hervorragend vor allem in einem Land wie
Dänemark wo es so viel Windenergie gibt
und so viel
erneuerbare Energie insgesamt läuft es
gut richtig gut ist Fernwärme natürlich
wirklich nur wenn
sie nicht nur aus der Ferne kommt und
mehrere Menschen versorgt sondern wenn
sie grün ist wie ist dieser Prozess
organisiert worden eben
gemütlich oder naja
also wenn wir dann wieder von der
Fernwärme reden dann war die
verschiedenen über Jahrzehnte und die
ist dann langsam umgestellt worden und
das sieht man schön in den Grafiken wie
wie Gas weniger geworden ist vor allem
Kohle auch und Öl und wie die
erneuerbaren Energien und darunter auch
Biomasse was ist drin ist wie nachhaltig
das ist und da haben sie mit einer
CO2-Abgabe gearbeitet haben wir
verstanden auch die Arbeit
verhältnismäßig klein ist in Dänemark
also hatten auch im europäischen
vergleichen relativ kleine Rolle
gespielt aber
man hat natürlich mit mit wie eingangs
gesagt mit Verboten und
finanziellen einmal Anreizen das ist
sagen Subventionen auch um vor allem die
alten Ölheizung in Dänemark
ist weit also bis zur Jahrtausendwende
jetzt haben wir noch soweit ich
Erinnerungen die 400.000 Gasheizung
immer noch in Dänemark von knapp 3
Millionen Haushalten die gibt es also
immer noch aber da Fällen auch die
Zahlen jetzt rasant natürlich weil die
die Wärmepumpe in hervorragende
Alternative ist wie gucken sie
eigentlich in Dänemark auf diese
deutsche Diskussion
verwundert würde ich sagen also
ja das ist ja nicht ausgedruckt weil
also erstens die die politische Debatte
ist finde ich persönlich und auch was
ich so sehe was meine cousinenten
Kollegen schreiben ist zu tief
verwundert also dass man sich in
Deutschland fast eine vielleicht nicht
Regierungskrise aber auf jeden Fall so
tiefen regierungsstreit leistet über
über die wärmewende das ist ein Ding ein
anderes Ding ist das mediale bilden
Deutschland ist nicht immer so schön
also Heizungs Hammer und so weiter und
und Anspielungen auch an Plan wird
schafft und alles was schlimm und böse
ist wird jetzt auf
auf den Bürger sozusagen gedrückt und es
ist ja fast eine Identität politische
geworden in Deutschland das das ist
schwierig den denen zu vermieten dann
gibt es die technische Seite wenn man
die wenn man die Experten in denen mal
fragen dann sagen Sie wo Deutschland
steht tatsächlich erstmal
so vor dieser wärmewende und das ist der
leichte Anfang das sind sozusagen die
niedrig hängende Früchte in der gesamten
Energiewende und wenn schon da der
Jammer entsteht bevor die Industrie dran
ist bevor der Transportsektor dran ist
also die eher komplizierten Sachen dann
zieht das ja schwieriger aus für die
nächsten Jahrzehnten also für für für
und das ich wollte nicht darüber lachen
weil das ist tiefer Ernst dann die
Kapern könnte noch ein bisschen
aufwendiger werden und noch mehr Streit
bedeuten und da entsteht dann ein
besonderes Feuer und eine besondere
Wärme klasse dass wir sie heute hier
haben bei uns vielen lieben Dank ich
marschiere zurück in diese Runde und
fange mal bei dem Gedanken an das und in
welcher Form wir das auch ideologisieren
Sie
haben jetzt von zwei drei Seiten schon
gehört dass es nicht so richtig gut war
von einer energiestasi zu sprechen was
ist Ihnen
peinlicher dass sie das gesagt haben
oder dass ihnen ihre Leute nicht gesagt
haben dass die Bayern so was längst
machen und das ist ziemlich schlau ist
von den Bürgern zu wissen mit welcher
energetischen Versorgung sie zu Hause
unterwegs sind ich habe das ja auch
nicht gesagt das war ein anderer Kollege
es wäre nicht meine Sprachwahl gewesen
ich habe das auch in der Sprachwahl
nicht für richtig gehalten aber die
Ängste und die Sorgen sind natürlich
ausgesprochen groß weil nicht
strukturiert geplant wird wir haben in
Dänemark eine besondere Situation
5,7 Millionen Einwohner also 1,5 mal so
groß wie Berlin ein starkes
Fernwärmenetz über Jahrzehnte aufgebaut
und eine ganz andere kommunale Planung
womit die Ferne der Fernwärme Anschluss
eben auch möglich ist nicht ganz
übertragbar auf Deutschland auch was
Industriestrom und was Industrie wir
haben angeht nicht ganz übertragbar aber
eben schon vor zehn Jahren ja wir haben
auch ein Klimaschutzgesetz in
Deutschland geschaffen was wir haben ja
auch ein Klimaschutzgesetz geschaffen
was in Deutschland
derzeitig gilt wo mehr Förderung drin
ist als das heute bei Habeck drin ist
und insofern auf der Basis dieses
klimaschutzgesetzes sind ja auch die
Klimaschutzziele in den vergangenen
Jahren erreicht worden das heißt nicht
dass man nicht mehr weiter was tun kann
auf der Basis waren wir abhängig von
Putin auf der Basis sind wir jetzt in
die Situation gekommen dass wir sehr
sehr schnell sehr viel machen müssen
weil es nicht angefangen worden ist noch
nicht mal angefangen worden ist wie der
Kollege aus Dänemark ja gerade zu Recht
gesagt hat
in ihrer Koalition auch vor 40 bis 50
neue Gaskraftwerke zu bauen und das Land
weiterhin aber nicht weil wir das gerne
wollten sondern weil es war eine
Übergangstechnologie
gewesen das ist doch nicht wahr das war
doch auch ihr Plan gewesen und durch den
Krieg in Russland hat sich von Russland
gegen die Ukraine hat
und würden jetzt uns allen noch mal den
Gefallen tun zu fragen wie viel
Subvention ist eigentlich möglich und
wie viel ist zumutbar die Summen die da
genannt werden Herausforderung auch da
hören wir ganz kurz den Ingenieur da
möchte man ja auch profund wissen wer
hat Recht haben die Recht die sagen ist
so um die 40.000 auf eine 150
Quadratmeter Wohnung oder es muss dann
eigentlich auch noch die Stromleitung
und es muss eigentlich auch noch die
fensterdämmung und die Fußbodenheizung
also was sagen sie ist der realistische
Rahmen für so eine Größenordnung also
alle haben Recht die Wärmepumpe selber
die Technik diese kriegen das sind
40.000 kriegen sie schon einige Kilowatt
draußen nur wenn sie das Innenhaus
einbauen das nicht gedämmt ist das nicht
auf Niedertemperatur Heizung ausgelegt
ist dann müssen sie richtig anfassen und
dann stellt sich ganz schnell die Frage
lohnt sich das für dieses Haus noch und
ganz ehrlich in den letzten Wochen wenn
ich über Land fahre dann gucke ich mit
diesem mit diesem Filter aus dem Fenster
und dann in diesem Dorf wie viele der
Häuser für wie viele lohnt sich das die
überhaupt noch rum
du musst ja auch mal lesen vielleicht
untersteht zum Beispiel auch jetzt kein
Wolf gegenüber der steht ja auch der
Satz zum Beispiel drin das in Fällen in
denen es sich wirtschaftlich nicht
darstellen lässt nicht saniert werden
muss also nicht irgendwo ein schrotthaus
in Brandenburg hat ist nichts mehr wert
ist ja dass
das ich meine Lebensrealität auf dem
Land wo ältere Leute ein altes Haus
verkaufen und mit dem erlöst ihrem ihr
zwei Zimmer Apartment im Pflegeheim
finanzieren
sich so ein Haus kaufen und mit
Muskelhypothek renovieren und alles was
Arbeitsstunde darin ist das geht einfach
weil die beiden die das machen das bei
zehn Freunden auch schon gemacht haben
aber wenn die Cash zahlen müssen dann
wird richtig bitter